okay you guys are disturbing my god stop
staring at me you freaking weirdo
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to selfie tennis now I
haven't played this one before like the
space pirate but I'm directly off of
playing bat I am riding like a high from
playing these awesome virtual reality
games and this is next on my list
so it features what I can only imagine
is a twist on the game of tennis hello
you are freaky and you stop looking at
me and especially this one I saw this
guy earlier her lady I have no idea they
got clouds covering their private boots
I don't know who do to anyway so we got
this we got a ball [ __ ] I didn't like
that color anyway we got tennis racket
it's not exactly facing the correct
direction
boink oh that is weird
oh that feels weird ah oh oh I'm playing
right oh I'm playing with myself I get
it selfie tennis
Oh hahahaha [ __ ] sorry about the [ __ ]
throw ah bah ha ha ha okay okay here we
go Oh JA come on I'm gonna smack into my
desk back there oh oh oh I'm so bad oh
yeah okay that did something [ __ ] ah oh
oh it didn't quite do it
oh I'm better than this I can do this ah
[ __ ] yeah okay that's good huh oh it's
weird cuz it like backs
oh it backs up in time before I've hit
it oh but this is I'm playing tennis
look at me I'm into the New York tennis
tournament of tournament thing with Rob
Schneider and what's-his-face
Kevin Federline what is his name
god dammit ah okay oh uh yeah
oh look at you look at you look at me
look at me look at you I'm playing
tennis god damn it son of a [ __ ]
oh hey I don't know what did that yeah
oh he's dead
oh god he is dead sir sir look what's
that
what the hell Oh what what whoa oh I'm a
I'm a unicorn is this a way of telling
oh hey how about her how's it going
buddy what the hell it's so weird
hi I'm gonna do some deer Oh dad I'm not
right in the grundle oh he's so injured
oh hey oh geez excuse me and you Oh God
can I pick him up tonight ah there we go
that works kind of good little odd
though yeah okay
I wonder if you can play multiplayer
with this like with actual other people
that would be super cool yeah I don't
know how but I wonder if you could [ __ ]
your balls come on give me something
good give me something good to play with
myself
Oh give me some good I can do this oh
boy
you're out Oh boink yeah I've got a
rally going ooh
boink yes I've got hand-eye coordination
uh-huh yes not good I mean I know I'm
winning whenever I play against me but
still it back Yepsen [ __ ] you oh oh
that's weird oh that is really weird
ah okay we're fine you just yeah you
just go on your way cuz I got people to
deal with over here up nope yeah oh
Oh God oh let me spank my rump
let me spank my delectable rump
die already just fall down wow this is
good help there we go
ah Oh goodbye
Oh you stayed on that's not as cool gone
gone whoops whoops gone ah ah there we
go
good
yeah there we go got him oh wait now it
well that hardly seems fair because now
there's a bunch of dead bodies on the
ground
why did you repopulate the stadium when
Oh what is that can I hit that
ah
oh it's flying away
oh it's been oh well when did it get
impossible to hit okay look if there's
another serious try without killing the
entire neighborhood here cuz I yes hop
okay this is gonna be the one whoa what
the [ __ ] I had that yeah yeah yes yes
yes oh oh
try gonna be the one who's gonna be the
one right over into my palm and right
into my clutches this is so much fun I'm
having oh I got it ah look at me look at
me being all classy and [ __ ] win tennis
like a bug like a bozer oh I'm gonna get
the high score gonna have you I forget
ah I said it again with less stupid
okay the Heart Ball kind of a baseball
but I'll forgive it ah there we go
we just keep lobbying it to each other
we should to be a fun oh there we go
now I'm in it
ah there we go yes yes new record yes
yes fly Markheim who play at the tennis
I'm to quit YouTube and become a
professional tennis er that's what
they're called right tennis ears from
the great state of Tennessee ah
boink goddammit saw God don't jump don't
jump I kept wanting to jump I really
wanted to jump for it
yeah keep your eye on the ball keep the
B BAE on the ball keep it on the ball we
got it balls on ah ah [ __ ] yeah you got
in my way
interference ah ah there we go I gotcha
yeah whoa whoa Jesus that counts is this
sad yet I'm playing tennis with myself
in the virtual world I'm not even
playing it in the real world
ah damn it I swung that good what's up
thank you
there we go just short hops ah there we
go
Oh too much
don't jump ah ah get out of here get out
thank you get out goodbye come as if I
hit those woo something happened
okay whoa I did not know we were a high
above the earth that's really cool
actually I'm actually having a lot of
fun cuz it's oddly relaxing considering
I just played the Brookhaven experiment
tada yes yes back again with the right
at the mouth [ __ ] oh look at my shame
want to look at my shame I'm sure God I
tried to grab it God ah [ __ ] I'm so
beautiful I'm so beautiful ooh
doink yes yes yes oh oh whoa coming
close to a boundary there we're okay
everything's fine even though it went
dark for a little bit there come here
you yeah there we go
I'll go over yes Oh ah damn it
yeah Oh Oh No get up thank you oh boy
one away from the record ah ah blah okay
nothing is done
woo oh god damn it
[ __ ] you I got this Oh
Oh what the hell okay this is gonna be
the one watch this boink
oh so perfectly I know it's the best I
have clever things to say but I'm just
pacing myself be who has
I'm trying it you better get out of the
way selfie stick get it no [ __ ] oh god
damn it
Oh get out of here get out of here
wink okay here we go this is the one I
know I've said that before but I was
wrong again well apparently not whoa
[ __ ] oh not again why okay I'm done I'm
done how that one hurt all right okay
ow it was just a glow I just wanted to
get it really badly I keep forgetting oh
my god oh wow it's a huge scrape on this
so anyway that's enough selfie tennis
for now that is really fun it's really
immersive the physics are a little wonky
because if it twitches out of place for
just a second it Ness is yep but it's
okay so thank you everybody so much for
watching I got a lot more VR stuff for
you guys to see in the very near future
but thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how you think of
this game in the comments below and if
you want to see more VR games in the
future and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
this routine is boring me